Daniel everyone else has the review for
the post up they've had it up for weeks
there's someone who is not special I'm
getting it up NASA let's review the post
[Music]
the post so the post is directed by
Steven Spielberg stars Tom Hanks Meryl
Streep Bob Odenkirk was in he was really
good too takes place in the early 1970s
and essentially there were these
documents these top-secret documents
that chronicled the u.s. is involvement
in the Vietnam War
doesn't the documents show some shady
business it was all kept from the
American people but the press have a
duty to inform the people so the New
York Times gets a hold of it and they
run it then tricky dicky Sue's them so
then the Washington Post gets the rest
of the documents they're like should we
run the story should we're not will we
get in trouble too what is journalistic
integrity do I really have to talk about
how good Meryl Streep and Tom Hanks are
in this review what am I going to shock
you like guys they're really good but
this movie is if I had to choose a word
informative it's a very informative
movie about a thing that happened in
time some people already knew the story
a lot of people didn't I didn't so I
thought it was an interesting story to
learn about not done in the most
interesting way I'm saying nobody is
ever gonna be like all right no I want
to watch movie do you want to watch
movie great oh dude if you want to watch
a movie have you seen the posts Oh treat
yourselves I don't really don't see that
happening I've used this comparison
before but the post reminds me of one of
those movies where if you're in history
class in junior high or high school and
you possibly run across this chapter the
teacher will play a movie to show you
get kind of the situation that was
happening the post will be that movie
it's one of those played in the
classrooms to educate the class kind of
movies I do get the movie's importance I
mean let's face it this movie was made
because of you seeing fake news movie
was made pretty sure Spielberg
fast-tracked it to get to this Oscar
season not waiting for the next one
because who knows if that news gonna be
present still no no but as we have seen
a resurgence of the US government versus
news is an important movie to do now I
feel like this movie would have
benefited from being a thriller that
goes John Grisham stories this would
have been a good John Grisham story and
I said I need a [ __ ] chase sequence
or anything like that but there's a
difference between informing the
audience and making them feel it movie
just didn't do that like there's a scene
I set up in my seat is like alright a
courtroom scene those are always intense
that is your ace in the hole for the
climax of this movie but note they're
like all rise and then they leave
well that was court I guess it was if 35
millimeter film was still the norm I
would be like there was a real misery
this movie doesn't really have a moment
like that that moment in the third act
that just impacts you and leaves you
thinking about this movie it's an
informative movie of action and
consequences that results in a series of
events that leads from the beginning to
the end of the film and then the film's
over cuz in the end as an educational
piece actually really did enjoy this
movie and the performances were
top-notch if you're interested in that
element of it the historical element of
it a spotlight at casts on the premise
of the government not liking the press
just isn't a new thing
round round we go those are the wheel
and give it props for that I know it
feels like I started in on this movie
more than I intended to I guess it's
easier to address what you didn't like
about a movie than what you did
sometimes specially when the movies at
drama go in for an Oscar clearly and
that's it even credit where credit's to
the movie is a very well made period
based the period being early 1970s but
if Spielberg had amped up the tension
level and made you feel the gravity of
the situation in this scenario about
this newspaper company that's going to
take on their government it's given one
of the best movies of the year
regardless the post is well made
educational Oscar bait no alcohol
required alright guys so the post have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]